you are I'll give you a credit you are
very committed to your dancing you don't
need to be you don't need to be because
because people love the song so much you
could probably just go out there and
sing them and not move around too much
but you really try to be a good dancer
do you consider yourself a good day I
have to be committed because I'm not
talented you know I'm not a good dad you
see that I think that the comedy the
humor as it were comes from the fact
that you know I don't know what I'm
doing I'm not trying to be funny I'm not
trying to be wacky and funny the comedy
comes from me really committing and
trying as hard as I can to dance like
James Brown or Michael Jackson because
I'm just really uncoordinated goofy
white guy really trying hard I can't I
can't relate to you at all I don't know
what that's like but it sounds horrible
for you you know it's funny I you
actually it's I think that even though
you're not technically a dancer and you
say you're not good you channel so much
sort of desperation into it it actually
makes you good I really don't think
you're good we have a quick clip just a
quick montage take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
crazy
I had my skeleton removed a few years
back your help good yeah no scholars
rubber nerve really help
you